[Music]
there's a new app that teaches men how
to perform oral sex
[Applause]
Wow
you didn't even let me get to the joke
party you're so thrilled
what's head no no no no no no wow this
woman is very excited to talk about this
alright well do I even do the joke now
why not it's not better than what she
was doing over there get this lady
there's a new app that teaches men how
to perform oral sex by licking the phone
screen yeah ladies you can tell your man
has this app if the first thing he does
down there is try to punch in a passcode
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she gave me a book
I thought we had a real human connection
here
I thought something real is happening
here hold this up on camera no
ridiculous she's probably not she's
probably not dissatisfied by inept
immoral sex either
all just a scam to get that book on
camera yeah she pretended to be unhappy
with her sex life right to draw me in
right and then gave me a book to sell
what's happened to our country clever
marketing
God good luck with that and the book -
okay here we go folks